okay we're back he's peeing right now
he quieter it's like louder than the
rainstorm I know the acoustics are
really carrying it to me hey form a
larysa okay that was definitely her what
is she is this just like a game to her
or something
Clarissa come back this is going out or
wait I can the handprints are amick
touch do you know who did that please
tell me it's like a known thing
teenagers here do or something buckle up
buckaroo out and just let go and I do
this for my own peace of mind I in the
Cascade Mountains of Washington the Navy
opens the world's largest radio
transmitter it's 1 million watts can
flash a message around the world
inattentive yeah the US Army or a second
hey kids want to play a game they're
talking about it's talking about the
Navy hangman be sharp and listen mister
this is going to tell the classification
board a lot about what can be expected
of you in the future how many questions
will you be able to get in the allotted
time [ __ ] all like a test hey why are
we being tested what did we do 9 like a
classroom u.s. army radio communication
school that's this stuff Charlie now
you're swinging it all goes into your
final ratings you want to get a good
rating don't you and [ __ ] go
I don't you want to be a good soldier
yeah sure this property could be kept w
week or two week evening
I feel like I'm stuck on a tilt-a-whirl
oh just keep the pointer on the buggy
question to know what did the
communications officer is at Fort Mill
Newark all codes cookies no you're
cooking coded radio transmitters have an
important job and you wouldn't want them
to be unqualified no I mean like any job
right
like anything right
and through all our times the scene has
ruled our brain are you doing okay one
last round and you've cleared your exams
ready
well how many officers died in the
sinking of the USS that's not 97 brave
men and women died on the USS
cannellonis 85 officers 12 passengers
it all adds up to another fact for the
classification board just another fact
among many
[Music]
take my I like the United States
submarine catalog is shown for the first
time in Pacific waters patrolling
through the enemy
needed to escape the commander looks out
over the ocean surface
ken Aloha was lost today lost at sea
near why why are you testing me testing
us
I don't know what me being good at
trivia that is true we need standardized
tests okay about that I'd really prefer
not to enlist itself
[Music]
what are you and the panic of them don't
[ __ ] what I am bad it was not fun take
it slow and easy you've just had
experience yes yes very good
this has been united new this is just
unbelievable anyone anyone that's gotta
be Clarissa
let's get her and get out of here or use
her radio and get out of here but let's
just get out of here I can't go to the
right guy
here's a door right here
[ __ ] works now alright closer where's
that [ __ ] Clarissa's asleep right now
be still so was not to wake her it's a
joke or something
I hope yeah jokes cross your fingers
Clarissa oh my god you actually came I
mean it did take you long enough but
still it's good
I've been sitting home yeah I keep my
word I told you I'd come and I can't
yeah you did but be honest did you come
because I needed help
or did you come because there was a
radio Clarissa I want to hear it from
Alex no Clarissa of course not the
radios are way out you're the way outs
appendage well this appendage found the
radio so remember that when you're back
at home safe and sound and snuggled with
your stuffed animals speaking of the
radio where is it I don't know I can't
get it to do anything I want Alex want
to take a look at this yeah no this is
this is like a low-frequency thing it's
just meant for the base it won't I don't
think it can be no your problems give
you a friendly and sympathetic hearing
wait Joan is something something just
happened we got Clarissa is there
anything like can we cut her down with
something
Clarissa I would have swore she was in
here I'd her gone then dead oh maybe
this was the the thing the radio she was
using if we can get it to I mean she got
it to kinda work
so yeah it only broadcasts with him
within a short space it's not gonna do
what we need to really how do you know I
just know all right
I can tell from here well I'm still
gonna try
[Music]
yeah the other Karissa oh thank god
Clarissa oh my god why would she do that
she's silly she's definitely the clown
looks like I can't believe this I can't
believe she would do that over I mean
things are bad right now but yes we
can't get her so I just don't really
like her
Jonas this is so horrible like she
wasn't like that hot for the one else I
don't even know what's in we we should
get to the others like I can't even
imagine telling him or or how to tell
the money
we'll we'll figure it out this is
unbelievable
[Music]
Wow there's no way she got up from that
right like there's no way like she's a
lot let's get the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ]
[Music]
are you trying to pay but I need check
it out that's a weighted chicken nuggets
bang that game okay I guess it's rent
time yeah we gotta go get to the real a
profit let's hope it's less eventful
okay that's guy let's go this [ __ ] down
here
you got your chicken nuggets babe a you
know got them chicken nugget yeah yeah
yeah I got them checking a nugget yeah
[ __ ] right [ __ ] way
[Music]
I am didn't realize just how much woods
there were this is like like a genuine
four it's like what 20 square miles or
something it's like half the island yeah
I thought it was just gonna be a park or
something there is a park but it's part
of the woods but I just want to make
sure you know that we know where we're
going
yeah of course it's just over the river
and through the wood like the song yeah
but in the song the horse knew the way
to carry the sleigh through the white
and whatever snow and I think we'll be
fine trust me that's all I want to hear
you know this whole place really
creepily reminds me of a park or woods
I guess near where I used to live it's
really kind of felt just like this oh
yeah what was that we called Peabody I
think I'm trying to remember the sign
but like half the letters had fallen off
so it's spelled T pork my dad was really
happy to move here you know he said the
schools were safer less knifings per
capita I guess he never considered the
danger of whatever is happening right
now but you know yeah we once had a mall
Santa who was kidnapping kids I think
that's been so far the scariest thing
that's happened well I mean to be fair
that does sound pretty scary
over the woods and here we go
this thing's so weird-looking apparently
it's 400 years old there's a cafe in
town named after it and next on the tour
of Edwards Island an old bush well I
think this stuff is interesting it's
four centuries old you're not impressed
by that it's a tree so [ __ ] really no
there we go Jesus no that's resting [ __ ]
outside he loves that hello was a family
go
okay
why is there a cable car here couldn't
they have just made like it's like going
on a gondola ride I don't know if I'd
say it's neat it looks less than
welcoming or at least it doesn't look
very it's a little scary but right needs
us
so yeah yeah I know I know
all right well let's just see if we got
to take the unconverted running how's
the invention of ovens
that
the [ __ ]
across weekend
yeah all right
it says it's the I don't know catbird
station and the callsign is weird sixty
point eight the dial doesn't go that far
huh
[Music]
the catbird station was built to detect
any enemy attempting a strike from the
air when operational it was fully
outfitted with an SCR 271 antenna and an
early version of oth which stands for
over the horizon a radar system used to
detect targets at extreme distances all
right [ __ ] boring yeah yeah yeah I
get a play game at a history lesson yeah
yeah
see it's like why would I go there I
think this is the engine it's not even
warm yeah
no juice
it's not unless I'm doing something
wrong it's not working no power I mean I
would think if it had power these lights
would be on okay ready go in this
[ __ ] building
power transfer station 167 hey just what
we need okay that's a little strange
what why wouldn't they lock it I mean
somebody should have locked it
maybe there's no need like there's
nothing here to steal or something all
right I'll go with that just cuz what
else am I gonna do about being
terrorized on an island by unseen forces
really makes you miss television well
maybe if we get the power working you
can catch up on the soaps I found the
circuit breaker wait like the first
thing it says is beware of overload do
not attempt to restart without
supervision so I don't know we have to
have power Jonas we can't start the
thing without it and if we can't start
the thing we can't get to Ren just let
me do it okay that way if something bad
happens I can handle pulling two
switches I really just don't like I
can't think of a way to delicately put
this all right it's easy okay it's your
barbecue here we go baby what did you
flip cuz it kind of did the opposite of
what we wanted I flipped the it's the
only one Jonas what other switch could I
even flip oh good point the lips
that's that's God I haven't heard this
in forever
this is something my mom used that I am
so tired of this funhouse bull crap
we did it
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] okay I got a cot now was that
there Alex are you alright
not funny not funny
opposite total opposite of funny it was
worth it
what a night huh what a night um what
does that mean what do you mean what
does it mean I'm just saying this this
humming like a barracuda
barracudas don't hum well this one is
let's dip in the Lord
I need like chicken teriyaki or
something
well when you look at that it didn't
collapse that's one good thing that
happened tonight yep right I mean I mean
that's what Ren made it sound like yeah
well I don't know about a lot but a few
times yeah I can see this place being
cool like in the summer or even in the
spring
some people camp here but it's weird I
don't know why they just leave their
tent looks kind of dumpy like I don't
know like it's been abandoned they've
been abandoned but seriously it's nice
having a little getaway like this so
close to you yeah it's pretty nice it
can be pretty nice that you used to come
here a lot as a kid right to the islands
I mean I mean that's what Ren made it
sound like I mean it must have been nice
having this right here just a little to
our boat right away right I only mention
it because my family trips were wait
wasn't this we passed this a minute ago
right and it wasn't burning I am
honestly don't remember but yeah my mom
would always take us to Missouri just
awful fascinating
we used to come here a lot as a kid
right to the islands I mean I mean
that's what Ren made it sound like now I
mean it must have been nice having
satisfaction actually weird is going on
they do you ever get deja vu cuz I just
got the biggest one I've had in a while
it's like practically a stomach ache I
mean sorry if I'm rambling here are you
um I mean what are you thinking are we
lost or is it something else
I mean well just let me know it's like
you used to
wait haven't we done this before we're
going in circles or something
huh it's just me
oh the ball moved that was weird
okay
is that
this is new
it kind of stinks yeah it smells like
it's been sitting in a diaper for a
month
[Music]
take that ball who's there so it's just
I'm taking a picture of the ball moving
not you're kicking just so you know all
right who are you all right who are you
maybe don't antagonize whoever pick it I
think they have a sense of humor
oh my god it is crazy okay
can we like get out
okay I'll plug that hair
how am I is this an optical illusion or
something
tell Michael to break up with Clarissa
it's for the best
[Music]
well what do you mean wait wait we've
done this before it's alright we must
have just missed something I it was
weird you were gone for a minute I did
this I did the repeat thing again and my
reflection talked to me talk to you what
what did it say or was it like anything
you could even he said that I should
tell Michael to break up with Clarissa
which is of course totally useless said
ha this is that's just like they are
more in the cave SuperDuper old but in
my new condition
you know I didn't realize I felt like a
pressure in my head until right now
maybe doing that to fix the loop but
whatever you did help something like
that feel any better
maybe remember all the times we trekked
through here now no not really I mean I
remember the ball everything the bad
[ __ ] no
I guess that [ __ ] it just happen right
I don't know I feel like I just woke up
there treason you think so babe let's
just keep going and get read
so having fun yet
I'm so glad our families are uniting
Alex this will be a grand adventure for
the two of us what do you think they
want the ghosts I think it's usually
like justice or something
vengeance yeah
I just hope they want to like play
soccer every once in a while and that's
it
oh the to Jack's carpet Jack Mitchell
and Jack lab they used to hang out
together all the time and they carved
their names into this bench on a school
trip once you don't care do you know
please keep going
forget it
[Music]
is that Nona
[Music]
did it don't okay just don't move okay
don't come anywhere near me no don't
Nonna come on it's us you can see it's
us it's me and Jonas this night has
turned banana bread really fast and I'm
seeing things and forgetting things and
I bumped into you once already and it
was horrible
we haven't this is the first time we've
seen you since the beach be that as it
may I've seen an Alex so just look
you're not gonna talk about my
grandfather you're just gonna stand
there politely and tell me if you've
seen Clarissa cuz I've been looking
we're here because we think rent is
somewhere in the woods have you seen him
no not ran okay well listen nona
you should come with us that way we're
not all you know separated I'm not going
anywhere with you well right okay hey I
get it I just hold up a second no no
okay don't come near me
come on Alex just back away no not it's
me Alex remember can you just can you go
to the comm tower and wait for us we got
the lights on there and no Nona you
should really come with us it's better
to stick together better for who Nona
come on for everyone for all of us
no ma and the comm tower is where it's
the cloud Buster at the edge of town
can't miss it and you you're really you
really yeah no no it's me Alex
alright bye
we're hard at our I guess and girls a
peach
[Music]
[Music]
and a chicken hey just for me I want to
know back at the bridge why'd you flip
the switch yourself I don't want you
could have let me do it
Oh to impress you of course why would I
do anything except to delicately enhance
your opinion of me okay all right okay
that must be the weigh station and
actually help me understand why would an
island need anything like that anyway
like nobody's going anywhere doesn't the
whole thing just go in a circle I bet
you know I bet you know exactly why
there used to be tracks here and you're
holding out on me
can I ask you something of course you
think I'm kind of a slacker idiot right
like I wouldn't find any of this stuff
interesting Jonas I think you're smart
come on what are you talking about hmm I
don't know
I just sometimes get these like whiffs
of I don't know I can't think of the
word for it maybe it's stress like from
what's going on right now you think I
don't know stress I know stress hey guys
Jesus it took you forever to get here
what happened I've been scared out of my
mind hearing things we came all right
we're here to rescue you so just be
appreciative I can start pick your
methods do you have like any idea what's
going on
okay that must be the weigh station and
actually why would an island need
anything like that anyway
Oh Jonas we're repeating the same stuff
again we are there's your boy hey Ryan
we made it finally
Ren is he and shock ha I think I
remember reading that this well is
supposed to be the first thing ever
um built or whatever on the island back
in the sixteen hundreds it doesn't have
a sign or anything it used to I think
Hey
[Music]
[Music]
there we go there's the red
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean Corrine must have used this to
call us I look smashed
there's
what's he doing I don't know like
sleepwalking but the last time we got
stuck we used one of these things to get
out of it so I'm not just messing around
right now
yeah I remember I remember kind of
[Music]
heywhere Brendo he was standing right
there I thought I thought this would
have fixed it like last time didn't it
the time stuff yeah I mean I think I
think it did I don't feel as foggy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
when crap I don't maybe we shouldn't go
near him what's what's happening to him
I have no idea I mean I know they say
don't believe somebody with the spine
injury but it's like we got to do
something
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Jesus Ren are you
[Music]
feels
[Music]
what are you can we help you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Peggy Adler
that old woman Holy Mother of God
you guys God when you're alive I am I am
well why was that a question at first
why why is this why actually thanks for
coming by the way I'm getting sure why
is this happening I mean I've been here
I visited this place like 15 times the
islands haunted Ren wears a Thursday so
you gotta come see a bike haunted with
memories or elevators on their period
haunted the second one
is this thing working you looking
hearing it out there and uh cotton
Edwards Island where the [ __ ] is the
comm tower that heart into her whatever
I meant the comm tower on Edwards Island
hey she listened to us great so if
anyone can I'm trying to communicate
with does she know how to even work that
stuff doesn't we should get back there
before she freaks out and runs away
again I think that was our cue then it's
kind of a shortcut back to the
communication tower if we go through
this fence shouldn't take that long I
think it's actually locked not from this
side it's a little latch I could see it
from the window back to the comm tower
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] fire
Barry couldn't be like a lot clearer
Jesus oh man you know what just jumped
in my head just completely randomly that
showing the it was a horse ranch or a
horse farm but but that makes it sound
like they have a little Cabbage Patch
field of horses the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
wait there was a there was a show and a
horse ranch year ago out and save them
we took over a stable and our band
played and you you ditched that test
again right to bring us a new ham
because during the soundcheck
we blew ours none of this is sparking
any synapses okay what is the story she
had already blown off this like super
important for school placement aptitude
test once and why'd you do that um I
think she was indisposed you know I uh I
can't even remember anyways she was
gonna retake it and on the day of I had
to emergency call her way out and uh
just picture like Little House on the
Prairie
I don't know what that is it's a really
you don't know what Little House on the
Prairie
wait you blow off an important test to
get him an amp really that was the thing
you did yeah no total super friend
status you know and the funny part is I
taken that same test after dosing a
bunch of cough medicine and I still aced
it so she would have blown it out of the
water and even knowing that she still
came out to help me that's awesome right
I don't know I think you probably should
have taken the test really even if at
the time she didn't care
and it feels yeah oh crap this isn't it
this is just coming out with speakers
and the roof thing isn't it all right I
said that stupid thing she doesn't sound
good right she sounds a little off I
don't know her well enough she's just
tired when we're all tired
I know Brett how I would have been tired
by now if all we'd been doing was
drinking and laying on the beach yeah I
guess just I'm so glad I took that
second brownie what it's kind of you
know it's just about story second
brownie run please tell me this is a
joke okay this is a joke right why would
this be a joke I'm not joking wait
you're not messing with us
you seriously took another one but it
was like it was like half of one all
right it's just to level me out it'll
it'll bring me back up that's what it
does you better pray to whatever God
scares you the most it does level you
out cuz if this screws us up you're on
summary probation don't say that that's
not that's not nice
this thing doesn't work not getting
anything I'm getting something
but it's like I don't know hey Nona
night's still going huh
we heard you on the speaker system you
got that working that's about all I got
working sorry I was like weird earlier
but hey have you figured out what's
going on yet you have to know something
it's been ghosts Nona ghosts are going
on the blackouts the hallucinations
it's Alban ghosts ghosts really yeah and
it would really help with you could just
jump to the believing us part would save
a headache oh oh I got it this is great
this is perfect I know exactly what to
do do you yeah totally it's Maggie Adler
Maggie Adler yeah she has a boat had a
boat I mean her house Manor or whatever
it is is behind a huge gate you can see
it coming up here from Main Street
no I know but the keys to it are here
somewhat readily available my sister
Allie worked at the parks office in town
she had to deliver that old woman her
mail every day I know that they have the
key okay so no no we are not we are not
gonna go with the plan the first plan
put forth by the group's resident
burnout hey come on I'm not a burnout
okay well and I'm not saying it's the
best plan but what other plan is there
really Jonas oh I don't know fix the
radio find Clarissa set fire to the mug
shop and these are just off the top of
my head
yeah I'm still worried about Clarissa
but we don't know where Clarissa is I'm
not saying literally do that I'm just
there's other things we can do hmm
but there isn't Renne understand it is
completely your fault that were in this
to be
sorry carry on but Ren look at reality
you dragged us out here you had Alex
bring the little uh-oh shut up everybody
look here's something cool a phone ID
stop making Alex uncomfortable and talk
about this instead
look Jonas it should be obvious to even
the cheap seats that you're the only new
weirdo who throws this whole social
harmony thing we got going on out of
whack
I mean we all grew up heist you know
there's no television cameras here right
take the energy down a notch Alex I am
NOT putting my life in his hands
this whole thing has been a complete
joke to this guy I can't believe you're
even kind of defending him Jonas the
stories I heard about this guy he's a
maniac
okay he's gonna trash our only
legitimate means of getting out of here
if you buy into this crap legitimate
means what do we be talking about you
have no eyes stop it stop the collective
neuroses call a truce okay yes please
look I don't care what caveman Jonas
says there is a vault at Maggie Adler's
house and the key to her house is back
on Main Street in the back-up plan for
when this thing fails spectacularly is
two of us have to stay here by the
semi-functioning walkie talkie
fine by me alex has the radio are you
okay to go into town not that you not
that you wouldn't really anything to get
me office okay this tower and away from
this specific configuration of yelling
people would do wonders for me right now
she shouldn't you shouldn't go alone
we don't need like three of us up here
yeah I'll totally go
it's my like brilliant idea or whatever
you kidding your food is gonna start
kicking in any second beyond that you're
a completely unreliable basket case I am
NOT a basket case just shut up both of
you
sorry okay keeping in mind who you've
been able to depend on the whole night
yes
keeping in mind who you're tired of
keeping in mind who's taller who do you
want coming with you yeah your oldest
pal oh my god
Jonas
ah thank you what first you let me sweat
it out for like two hours in the woods
it to go gallivanting around with this
guy and now you're still picking him
over me
him him him Wren we're still we're still
doing your whole plan you came up with
who cares if you're on the home or the
away team I want to be on the Alex team
I want to feel like like I want to be
like needed just just fine whatever
have fun you two this isn't fun that's
the point
Oh God will you just shut up okay before
things get stupid again
good luck with the whole key thing we'll
be waiting guys so I gotta get the key
and then we get the [ __ ] out of here
[Music]
trebles
[Music]
[Music]
epiphany was rapping okay look I'm gonna
say I'm sorry now for what happened up
there but I do not want you to take it
as an admission of guilt stinking is
important because I don't think anything
that I said was that off-base hey I was
just the girl on the sidewalk watching
the car crash happen in slow motion but
you should nip it in the bud with Wren
when we get back just say you're sorry
fine for you I will apologize to Wren
when I see look and I just want to clear
the air too
just so Wren or whoever can't use it as
ammo against me but you might have heard
that I went to jail at some point I
never went to jail but I did beat up a
guy and get sent to juvenile detention
for it and I just wanted you to know so
it wasn't like a thing hanging over your
head or anything
why do you um why'd you do it
just my mom got sick and then she got
real sick and then this kid Timmy
Finster threw a baseball in my head and
yes he was joking but I don't know I
just popped yeah it was as stupid as it
sounds what happened to the other guy
hospitalized not for a while but you
know I tried to visit him after I got
out
he wouldn't see me my mom found out of
course and I never really squared it
with her in a way that I don't know
things never really work out the way you
want you know whatever are you are you
okay
it's not like I'm sick or whatever I'm
fine I'm not gonna say I'm a good guy
Alex but I'm trying to be and that's
really about all I can say you are a
good guide
[Music]
hey it's just let's go get that gay okay
[Music]
working on my night change yeah yeah
this is I want him
this is whatever but are you like
religious at all I mean my dad said your
mom wasn't but it doesn't necessarily
mean yeah I guess my personal feeling is
that the scientific process has given us
lots of how but not enough why so yeah
my parents were Methodist but my mom she
like practiced tonight's kind of I guess
I'm just realizing a lot of it's rubbed
off on me more than I thought but if
I've got it no I was just wondering if
you were yeah I could see having some of
that stuff could be timely
now just for processing this like having
some armor some aspects of it you can
help me I guess
oh today a little sad my god is that
Clarissa what well I was gonna say okay
but I'm not too sure about that have you
been the last time we saw you jumped out
a window I mean I thought we thought you
were dead I am not getting used to this
I'll be honest
maybe that ghosts or whatever might want
to help us somehow that the like point
of trying to China you think you can
control me IRISA yeah I'm trying to help
you this is this will don't you there's
a ghost in you right now they're they've
like perverted this moose sounds pretty
scary kids when you're wrong little
machine has no more heart than a brain
is she okay
oh she's Clarissa are you okay steady
just just take it easy I'm fine I can
I'm fine
okay just take it slow you've just been
through something back to normal I hope
back to normal what does that even how
did I get here we had I think we were
hoping you could tell us that the usual
answer to any question tonight has been
I have no idea sorry to say but this is
no different you really don't remember
anything
no I remember something I remember you
with that radio and I remember feeling
like you were the reason all of this was
happening wait it's Clarissa's turn
already yeah it's my turn what do you
mean it's klarissa's turn already I
haven't even asked one question
everyone's asking me I get to do the
asking now Oh guys okay I know you think
we're still playing truth or slapper
whatever but this is real so crap
Clarissa hasn't gotten a chance to ask
something yet so yeah and you of all
people should know what my question is
gonna because I'm not gonna waste it
Alex what did you do explain why me and
my best friend
look when we went into the cave we found
a thing and I use the radio to somehow
and I think it jump-started everything I
see but I mean come on like who knew
this would happen we thought it was a
weird trick of light or something
Jonas now you're seeing who you're stuck
to until graduation
Clarissa seriously I can vouch for this
this isn't her it has to be her fault of
course it's her fault
there's no other way this story goes she
why does it have to be my fault why does
it have to be your fault
are you kidding oh come on Clarissa I
swear to god the town looks at her like
she has a red-letter tattooed on her
freakin worship and the giant lit up
Christmas tree reason why is that
Michael is dead because of her because
of her like it would take a very sick
person to see it that way and I would
love to hear the explanation Michael was
gonna leave town he was free he was out
of here until this one convinced him to
take her swimming for one last God knows
what and he drowned he drowned in Horn
Lake while this one could barely flap
her arms the rest doesn't make it my
fault
anyone could have been there anyone and
then Jay would have had to watch him die
you unbelievable prick anyone wouldn't
have watched him die Alex anyone else
would have done something okay enough
seriously this is Clarissa this is so
like I can't even believe we're talking
about this right now
she's enough I mean it yeah I have but
right now we're gonna break into that
office and we're gonna find the key and
we're going to go home no no what do you
mean
so let's wait what wasn't Clarissa with
us like two seconds ago
that's crazy she was was like she was
just here did she run back to the gate
wait I'm getting it's deja vu again yep
this isn't budging well the walk looks
less than modern that's just brute force
it both of us it might splinter but we
should get in I don't get enough
breaking down doors in my life really so
I'm not gonna complain all right let's
see if Ren's plan was a good one or not
hey know what kind of jet that is not a
chance
cool carry on I think here's something
another pocket radio I think but there's
a dial it says that here's another one
it says their wall radios wall stands
for wave assisted lock ah they use that
frequency thing where each frequency is
like a key to open the doors around here
it says that you use them like
identification tags oh great let's hike
it back to the gate oh wait look at this
personal effects of Margaret Dorothy
Adler why would her stuff be here didn't
her family or what hasn't her family
been carting her things back to town we
can head back I'm just gonna here this
is OOP
yeah [ __ ] that
I think I'm Bridget and should consume
air but like this is a letter from earth
this island and its history is a lie Wow
well this is going somewhere
what what is that who's it for
to whom it should concern it says right
at the top I've been compelled by both
forces outside my control and oh my god
the cannon my own willful concern for
the safety of others to conceal the many
truths about Edwards Island further in
action
appears inside you'll find two wall
equipped radios I have commandeered the
old Cardinal station one 40.1 and used
it to relay clues to nearby beacons
buried throughout the area
find these beacons and the notes within
and discover the true chronicle of the
island Oh God
chores I don't care if the soldiers
secretly smoked opium or got the village
wives pregnant I just want to get out of
here all right just let me finish -
whosoever finds the material know that I
am discomforted for keeping it hidden in
ashamed for the wise I helped preserve
but also know that I acted in what I
felt were the best interests for all at
the time and truly for the interest of
time itself yeah okay let's get the [ __ ]
outta here [ __ ] Alex why are you
wearing that jacket it's like 75 degrees
the sun's out you know I thought you
said you were gonna go swimming anyway
god dammit that's why the Sun is kinda
out but when you're in the shade it
drops to like 50 follow it doesn't hey
Michael we didn't bring drinks did we
thought we said we'd bring drinks we
didn't bring drinks you didn't bring
drinks
today he turned out to be a flawless day
it really did ya know it did it really
did I wanted ring okay thought you'd
laugh at me why would I laugh at you
you're laughing right now not because of
oh my god forget it
[Music]
that guy should never just skip through
[Music]
it's been a spell since we did something
right I feel like I haven't talked to
you in a while have you been what's been
going on house classes how's
what's-his-face mr. Collins English
sorry I think yeah I accidentally left
my phone on the ferry cuz I do things
like that
Oh God you idiot go get it before it
leaves when I get back I want to hear an
Alex story I said that
so
um I'm glad we could all do stuff today
I'm glad you were cool with that I mean
I know you guys are really close and
like I know it can be annoying when
somebody starts keeping all their time
for their girlfriend or whatever so I
think would be cool if we could like
continue to do things together the fall
of us Michael uh he loves you like a lot
I'm sure you know that but he talks
about you all the time
Oh Alex did this and Alex let the frogs
out in science class isn't she hilarious
he just he thinks you're a cool girl so
I just thought you should know
I had to fight the skipper for it but he
didn't reckon how many squats I could do
what's it up to six only on burrito days
on non burrito days it's like eight glad
you got it back regardless so I actually
really want to cold something so I'm
gonna run into town and get like a soda
anybody want anything
now I'm good yeah get me a drink - sure
I'll be back
okay I'm here what's the story I want
the news I want the Alex first edition
what's going on
I know this was supposed to be our day
but I completely forgot I promised
Clarissa I'd do something with her so
thanks for sharing I know it's not what
you had in mind so but I owe you I don't
know [ __ ] your heart it's important to
me that you like Larissa Alex so tell me
the truth what do you really think of
her you want my unvarnished truth I
think you should dump her really why is
that why is that because I think she's
mean because I think she's a bully
because she likes to get her way cuz I
guess that's it well you see her more
than I do
she's in your class you know I never
noticed that's a good-looking jacket I
should ask for it back I don't like my
new one
feels like I got shoes on my arms or
something no way bucko Paco I thought
[Music]
Alex are you all right okay huh are you
are you back he been acting super weird
for like the last five minutes deep deep
do you know that yeah I let it go for
the first two but then it got stranger I
I don't know what was I doing um you
kind of slowed down then stopped and you
were just shuffling your feet like you
forgot how to actually move and then you
were kind of just muttering to yourself
about like sandwiches or something whole
thing was a weird little show like you
were having a stroke or something I was
yes you said it doesn't matter what's in
it potato chips
always improve a sandwich it was like to
yourself whatever oh did you get it did
it work do you hate me cuz it didn't
work it worked it worked
we got the well actually turned out to
be a radio but I guess it can open doors
and gates and stuff with different
frequencies really but we can open the
gate yeah we think ah good but if the
radio is the thing wait where's Clarissa
I guess the radio will open this somehow
hopefully give it a whirl
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay are you Jesus that house is
huge that lady really knew how to live
it's like the shared yeah
si Alli knew what she was talking about
she should anyway I mean she had to slip
back and forth here all summer
address Scotland's a gallon
[ __ ] out of here oh oh it's like a it's
like a boat that needs keys there are no
oars and before we go crazy it's not it
wasn't with Maggie's stuff back at the
office like with the radio now we
checked everything I locked myself out
of my house I'll just I can't help but
just stare at the deadbolt trying to
like hypnotize it to open or something
you ever do that um not really but we
can try that now if you think it'll help
I guess get this [ __ ] boat keys
let's go
it's a radio lock the woman sure does
offer antiquated security that is a
nifty gizmo you scared me
thought you were like Maggie Adler's
dead body or something how would that
make sense I don't know I'm in like a
heightened state right now
are you okay Clarissa I feel like I've
aged 10 years but for the time being
let's go with fine I'll talk to you you
look sprightly as ever
what is that supposed to mean Sharon
look horse is here so everyone's here
now we can just everyone's okay all
right that's a good let's just find the
keys to the boat or a phone or whatever
and just find a way home I promise we
can all keep talking and or fighting at
school on Monday yes Provine okay let's
focus up everybody find something and
hope that it helps come on luck
typewriter crammed full string
well string oh that's an attic thought
it was like a cat's toy or something
wanna come up yeah sure
the chest is pad locked needs a
combination mrs. Adler was either
paranoid beyond belief or just a very
tidy woman well she buried information
in sonically camouflaged containers
Jonas
my guess is paranoid okay
[ __ ] thing that
they've got basement or something over
there
man she owned enough books it's mostly
math I think her Ghatak thermodynamics
and religion she okay we get it she
liked the smell of paper fascinating
insight huh I'll miss her dearly put
some clothes on
remember that guy where are your parents
you kids better know Chad's lake house
yeah yeah that guy was a friggin weirdo
oh yeah come on push the frame a little
bit trying to walk here
desk huh Ren you were right there's like
a ledger here the Adler family does on
the island never doubt me and here's the
combination for the there's a padlock
chest in the Attic upstairs 29 1854 cool
are you doing okay yeah I'm all right
yeah we're going home soon so yeah
that's true certainly it's true
thanks to me
29 1854 it's a lot of radios and those
containers we saw at the town office oh
and like a map of the caverns she's
written here tune into the source I
think that means she couldn't have known
about the ghosts right tune in to the
source it's probably something about the
special radios you know huh is this ah
the boat keys forgot him perfecto go go
go go go get them all right we got keys
for the boat where Jonah's found them in
a chest upstairs so say thank you thank
you you're welcome
I was just saying it it's not directed
at you or anything okay
[Applause]
come down here please I'm not I'm not
listening to this all right
I'm not playing along anymore I'll just
come down and we'll drink to our future
come down okay it'll be all right I
promise all training is supervised by
very skilled inspectors stop just stop
whatever this is can't you just just fix
my friends please your friends are
finally they never been okay there's
nothing
so please I cannot bear your excuses
offspring you walked in here with clear
eyes the text is easy we speak of
something you see as simple pie I don't
wonder if I what if I don't huh what if
I just stand here and don't go along
with us refusal to cooperate we'll start
with the softball I spy with my little
eye radiation there is a wife's official
oh sorry you weren't even close
[Music]
[Music]
the television time for the bonus round
the picture I guess it's Maggie Adler
and somebody process we discovered way
for us to speak takes a little time and
far-reaching economic runs the waves the
waves we think I will use a picture says
someone uses for us and we will grow and
we will involve
to do so they had to keep it'll be a
great honor pops really to carry us
through this life and on to the next
[Music]
Wow that could have gone better
[Music]
tell Michael he should go to school here
[Music]
let's go I only think I'm gonna be sick
first it wasn't a dream or a vision or
something you and Clarissa standing am
living in just now was it Carissa
oh and by the way next time put some
actual effort into the game pretty
please
it felt like someone was shoving spiders
down my throat you want to see if it'll
start
not really
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
so we're no longer leaving
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me
[Music]
wow this is she's so mad
[Music]
[Music]
nothing makes me
[Music]
Wow what is happening
[Music]
[Music]
can't leave
you just have to go
[Music]
[Music]
alright there's already something in
here experiments and findings of
experienced phenomenon January 52
awesome oh man if this turns out to be
just prehistoric Home Videos
yeah I'm sure this is just yeah opener
you can skip this one
Alex yeah hit the button to keep going
Alex we fully absorbed this it's Maggie
and her friend let's move on you [ __ ]
hate them on the geek on
[ __ ] got on here
hey we're getting warmer I think so if
you look at the like lines or whatever
the bomb shelter should lead right into
the cave just like from another angle
according to this at least Oh but won't
it be like locked or something right
yeah how do we get in it's just like the
cave wall only steel or whatever bomb
shelters are made out of oh what she
knew about these things wow that's crazy
it says that to fix a temporal tear
that's a mouthful in the cave we need to
transpose to the other side and tune
into the source within itself okay but
we're not doing that right good question
yeah that's that's going a little above
above and beyond maybe I don't know
maybe she was wrong and it didn't work
maybe she tried and it didn't work well
something better work or were boned or
were boned precisely oh sorry this is
like this looks like the end but from
the from the wrong film thing no no no
wait this is something I actually
remember from that stupid radio tour
thing because it like sounded so weird
it's called the call and response system
it unlocks the bomb shelter this is
showing us how to do it see it says when
someone sends an emergency signal from
the cat bird station in the woods and
the receiving station confirms it it's
like a connected response thing okay any
other ideas preferably ones that aren't
unnecessarily complicated and I'm too
soon hanging by the thinnest spiderwebs
thread of relevancy
all right then Alex and me will head
through the woods do the call part you
and Wren can hang by the door to the
bomb shelter and open it when it's ready
wait wait I am I'm sorry I kind of zoned
out there for a second what are we doing
renin Nona our team soaring eagle and
you and I are awesome squad oh I want
that man we're splitting up to work on
some old-fangled machinery to open the
bomb shelter to get into the cave yadda
yadda yadda save our lives or whatever
all right break and if anything goes
wrong please don't tell me I won't want
to know ha we won't
this is [ __ ] anion
okay
we're walking
we gotta go [ __ ] up to tui woods
Ellis Alex okay are you are you back to
normal he went all red-eyed like when we
get possessed
it only lasted like a minute but we
should hurry up and do this before the
door on you opens any wider to them yeah
let's get this over with
haha no look it kind of made sense hey
guys wait did I get the plan wrong cuz
if I got it right no you didn't get it
wrong
we're just taking this way that's all
what the scenic route everything's the
scenic route there's no quicker way okay
well we'll be here good luck yes
[Music]
this [ __ ] taking 18 years this is
taken 18 years you know what time it is
it's 4:00 in the morning which is
usually about the time everyone decides
if they're going to bed or ordering
another three pizzas yeah what's your
vote usually in that situation yeah
never leave pizza on the table it's like
getting 11 and blackjack just double
down don't even think about it you think
this tuning into the tear thing is gonna
work like really yes undoubtedly without
doubt absolutely it's gonna work well
I'm glad you're confident as I just have
this feeling like these ghosts aren't
really concerned I just feel like
they're pretty confidence like they know
by Sunrise they're all gonna be shopping
for school supplies Jonas don't worry
about that we don't know what they're
thinking apart from them I want to live
in you thing I'll try not to worry
that's do this come on jump over yeah I
got a cow
now the station's up at the top of the
hill now
I hope this works right that [ __ ]
it's top of this hill I thought it was
like the other Hill
other stations up at the top of the hill
I hope this works God we're in another
loop deloo they always come at the most
appropriate times don't they yeah they
do
thanks for the update
you can't go up the [ __ ] left I guess
now the station's up at the top of the
hill I hope this works
yep I am also
Renne no no what happened what's wrong
with Ren Ren he's he had an accident he
he died I couldn't
no no come on Clarissa was dead too but
like bunny ears dead not dead dead
because apparently killing yourself
doesn't actually do anything here Alex
well it's the truth Jonas and I'm not
gonna stand here and fall for one of
these I'm dead no I'm not shuffleboard
swaps again
come on let's skip to the last chapter I
know what's gonna happen he he drowned
he took a fall I don't know he just he
just stopped okay just I don't want to
hear any more of your ghost garbage all
right give me some garbage and we're not
ghosts Alex we know you're in charge and
we know your plan and we also know that
your plan won't work it never does
so we have a proposition for you a deal
[Applause]
proposition like what she's gone will
pilot burn through the rest of existence
and there's nothing you can do to change
that but if you agree to let us take her
let her go quietly without fuss and love
slaughter the rest of your friends
like young Reggie they'll take her then
you know it's not often that we meet
someone your age this is mature issue
our Alex really understand things has
been surprising
as you were Alex we've enjoyed engaging
with you tonight
[Music]
the station's up at the top of that guy
that was my mouth feels like I just
Aidan tree
hello anyone there
what are they oh they're uh there's
somehow I guess there's somehow
broadcasting or something from whatever
we're doing we had a deal was done
what stuff yeah kind of slipped and fell
off the bridge like old doesn't going to
scribe the tear that helped it was hello
we're here we made it hello oh hello
this is Edward Island's emergency how
may I help you if you're being sat on by
a very large burglar just mash the dial
with your fist please
it is so nice to hear YouTube finding
the sunny side of all this we are well
we both are don't let her fool you
signal verified shelter tf1
open nice I guess it worked great
ok well meet you there right she was the
shelter over and now close the time hole
and save the day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah Frey oh yeah it's a long game
it's a long game yeah yeah yeah slightly
longer than you could have imagined yeah
yeah this isn't like a big thing but I
just want to say I think it would have
been cool us living together for for
whatever senior year and I'm just glad I
met you that's all I'm just glad we met
Oh Jonas you big SAP okay all right
that's all nothing to see here and now
we can go back to the whole escaping and
trying to live another day thing and
we're gonna be fine by the way there's
no you don't have to put it like it
would have been whatever to live
together we are gonna live together and
you're someday soon gonna eat all the
peanut butter and when I go make a
sandwich I'm gonna be mad all right
Jesus what are you doing jumping across
that there's another there's like
another way down here what Jonas I do
like a million jumping jacks a day this
is nothing oh I didn't realize sorry
I was going
he meant it though he something good
Kevin [ __ ] shattered most likes
it's Dennis dipping
[ __ ] changing it remembered like
double layers and everything come on I
can't okay I'm gonna I'm just gonna say
one thing and then I promise it'd be the
last time I bring it up tonight but you
know you screwed up with Ashley at the
concert right I mean it's not a giant
thing but still whose ash oh you mean
Amanda my really good friend Amanda
who's moving away forever that Amanda
yeah that Amanda who stole her mom's car
and I don't care if you didn't know she
didn't have permission to take it cuz
whatever fine but you knew you didn't
have permission to go to that show just
tell me is the last time I hear about
you stealing a car however and adverted
me my little heart can't handle the
excitement it'll be the last time but
maybe not for the reasons you think I
don't really care about the reasons just
for my own sanity don't do it anymore
oh and just so you know I took your
advice about Clarissa I'm not gonna see
her anymore
good I don't know I don't know how's she
taking it better than I thought she
would honestly but I don't know I'm
still waiting for the other shoe to drop
and she's depressed all the time I
really didn't want this to make it worse
come on let's get to the century before
the last boat comes I got to get the
visual aid for the history project and
then I just got to write the stupid
essay what history project they still
make you do like work with so little
left in the year unfortunately this is
it's just like a town history thing for
civics you know so he's forced me to
kind of I don't know and I mean it's
funny I don't know if I even want to be
here next year it's just all so flat
same people the same expressions I know
you think I have an uneasy street but
people looking at you all the time
wanting evidence that it's good that
they lived here that good things can
happen to people that are from here it
can get to be a real drag like how about
somebody else be captain of whatever for
one
your are great though and and you're
gonna be great whatever you do I'm sure
of it
you got spunk kid yeah well let's head
back before Karen strands is here you
know when we saw Uncle Pete last month I
wanted to ask him because he he got out
moving to New York and I asked him if it
was hard leaving know what he said oh
god Michael I have no idea I mean
knowing Uncle Peter he was probably
three sheets to the wind he said the
hardest part was deciding what to take
with him and what to leave behind I
thought it was I don't know for him kind
of almost touching oh my hell profound
I can't believe Uncle Pete Samir failed
actor and not teaching philosophy at
Berkeley oh shut up I cannot believe I
had to pick you up from the police
station because of Grand Theft Auto I
mean that is too funny oh shut up
come on Alex
shut up [ __ ] ah you got you know you
went bad again I couldn't get you out of
it
we should really we should get this done
now I'm fine let's we can go let's go
come on it's all right I think I can
hear rena noted down there
[Music]
there
that's good let's go [ __ ] no I just
always do the poster I mean you get the
option right the you guys doing okay
yeah it's we're fine but Rin wait
seriously an AP English all you to do is
make a fake book cover poster and is can
you like I want to just do this okay
we've blabbed enough let's get in there
this is important just just you've been
completely like I can't even remember
why we started hanging out I just don't
know what's happened let's get the [ __ ]
out of here this is stupid but can we
like take a picture why I don't know in
case things go bad and yeah let's do it
we're on a beach kind of let's keep a
shred of normal here alright let's take
it Alex get in here
you're not
all right once we're in there the door
won't open again since the system so
convoluted so make sure you're ready to
finish this while we go inside
[Music]
there's no like evil presence at all
back
thanks at the Corsa listen Alex I don't
want to say anything to Ren or Nonna but
the truth of it is I'm not feeling too
awesome right now it's kind of getting
worse
just hang in there Jonas okay I know you
feel like a garbage snowman right now
but we're almost done hey what do you
call a man who's short of time huh
mm no clue Tim you call him Tim oh yeah
it's not one of my finest it's it feels
like wrong to see one of these when
we're not in a time loop right yeah kind
of does wait it's Tim so what a radio
wave lock thing
[Music]
wait before look if something happens on
the other side of this door just don't
be stupid cut and run okay
if I turn into deadweight or start
freaking out just get to the boat do
whatever you have to Jonas we are all
getting out of here
I mean look we're about to fix this in
two minutes two minutes this is
microwave popcorn of a problem I'm not
asking I'm telling alright fine I'll
leave you with your guts hanging out on
the side of the road at the first
provocation that's what I want to hear
thank you wait wait wait wait okay you
know what there's there's like the tenth
time we've heard this song all night
there is something going on with like
why would this specific G it's probably
a trick Jonas the ghosts know we're
closing on booting them out and they're
throwing up distractions to distract you
maybe you're right maybe you're right
but I mean it's it's ghosts and I'm not
about to throw away the possibility this
is something else
I'll be fast but it's just too strange
all right I know what you're thinking
and Jonas I'm sorry but chances are
remote that this is like your actual mom
collect calling you from the grave or
something yeah but how remote really
deserve oh come on Jonas let's let's
just get in the cave and remember why
we're here okay can't you just help me
out with this please no no now really we
we have to finish this before it's too
late
okay okay
let's get the [ __ ] out of it sound to
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah yeah don't
they like don't even need to think about
its like 6 a.m. doesn't the place open
up again Karissa did you get lost
or are you just extraordinarily
forgetful we had a contract
run into the spinal column hours you
shouldn't be here for transition leave
for the boat before we get distressed
wait what contract what is she talking
about
didn't she tell you Jonas she tried to
course up for the rest of your futures
you did what don't be so harsh for her
desperation almost saved your life
I wanted to I tried to do what was best
for everybody not just Clarissa who
seemed already lost Alex whatever you
think you can do you can't are they like
coming back now or something God we got
a I don't know no we haven't been
whatever switched or whatever's going to
happen so there must still be a way to
reverse this okay what's the plan what
are we gonna do hit me with that dick
rebuff getting my fifth wind
we can't let us be too late oh this is
the wrong time to go dumb but I kind of
am you have any ideas plans anything
well I mean the gate looks it's what's
been happening with all of them after we
mess with it it just goes blank to get
Clarissa back I can't see how we're not
gonna have to turn this one back on but
don't ask me how
I have no earthly idea what about non
earthly ideas no none of those either
[Music]
okay all right this is this is something
hopefully good
[Music]
look what's happening why isn't it
connecting or whatever it does I mean
are you doing it right still
now let's just whatever happens just oh
yeah this subway oh where am I this
isn't God uh ghost is that you to close
the hole well you're gonna find out it's
not that simple
the horses have already left the barn or
you could just like leave you know
there's there's still time to not be
complete monsters about this and do the
right thing here the right thing oh I'm
sure it's very easy for someone like you
to dictate terms when you've never
really been challenged God yourself
spoiled you don't even know the cost of
things
getting started already
joined with ours
[Music]
[Applause]
real corner design
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh hey I didn't even know you're home
you're always so quiet it's like living
with a little fairy tale mouse wait I'm
this is our house
I'm not I can't play amnesia spy girl
right now seriously pretend to snap
Ren's neck on your own time I've been
like struggling with the stupid speech
the graduation thing I don't want it to
be just the usual blah blah we've come
so far type stuff it should have like a
point right she'd bring you to your feet
about something graduation speech is
that what we're talking about ah man you
haven't been listening at all it's okay
this is really boring
I'm guessing mom probably told you about
my scholarship to state right I don't
really know how I feel about it
I mean I feel it's not like it's a bad
thing it's a good thing obviously what
is that's great congratulations I mean
that that's awesome
thank you Thanks it's just you know it
seems like half the teachers are alumni
and actually I'm about to be really
arrogant and presumptuous and say mean
things for no real reason other than I
think I know better so forget it
I'm bored you enough I'm boring me come
on I'm not gonna judge no no really I'm
talking out of my ass it's fine okay so
let's say you have two choices one is
safer you know what I'm not even gonna
shred it in whatever look I'm thinking
of not going to school at all any school
I'm thinking of just forfeiting the
money and not doing it um okay but do
what instead just move somewhere out of
state get a job learn on the job
learn unfettered I guess listen to the
thousand one things I love about you
Alex the fact that you don't care what
people think about you always have
around the top five that's why I asked
my little sister for advice although
thanks I like to consider myself a
one-woman Roadshow of baseless yet
staunch opinions yes exactly
but anyways all of that is why I need
you to tell me really what do you think
I should do go to school here
or take a chance and leave Michael I
think you should leave just go and see
what happens
Alex just get good friends okay and when
you're with those friends just say yes
to everything and keep away from boys
when you talk to them it feels like
you're performing but also stay away
from girls who look you in the eye for
too long and mats every beer with the
water and take classes outside of school
oh come on Michael we already have a dad
you should know we all live in the same
house this is just this is a
just-in-case package okay just in case
I'm not around and I love you and you're
amazing that's it so I love you too but
soon I shall be so I cannot remember any
but the things that never happened yeah
I I don't know
hey she's waking up maybe don't get up
immediately wait wait is Clarissa is she
okay yes I think I'm I might have um
Clarissa who's Clarissa it was only you
me rehna Nona but that's it just us
maybe you're just like I think we all
had visions or something during the
nights caused by the ghosts and time
stuff I don't think any of it was real
really was yours like about someone
named Clarissa maybe because nobody like
that came when I saw
Michael a few times back when we were
here on a kind of an accidental trip I
would see like my dad sometimes but I
don't know why I mean he's still alive
obviously but you know like who knows
really what happened
I can't believe everything that happened
I just I feel like we should tell
everyone we know go on a freaking book
tour but let's make a pact to just keep
it like ours it's only our thing it
happened to us and nobody else has to be
involved I don't know like it or not
we've had a have a shared thing now
shared insane thing that I don't think
will get reset once like graduation hits
or something is this Rin didn't you lose
a book holy crap this is it thank you I
lost it on the way I thought for sure
some commuter would have just tossed it
overboard hey that reminds me what were
we we were talking about something
stupid right before Alex woke up prom
prom prom are you going Alex are we
supposed to still spike the punch or
just bring in flasks hey do they even
have punch I guess I mean if I find a
date you know I'm not gonna go stag I
have my dignity
Ben Owen's will ask you or rather he's
going to ask you unless I physically
prevent him yeah you can do better
all right you know what it's picture
time oh my god come on
no not yeah I guess we should tonight's
been um noteworthy noteworthy that is a
way to say it yeah I'd probably say it
another way
let um let's actually move outside so we
can get the light
sure Wren what is that book anyway I
don't know I can hardly make heads or
tails out of what the hell he's talking
about half the time here's good for the
yeah just here
like look like this here when I was
younger I could remember anything
whether it happened or not but soon I
shall be so I cannot remember any but
the things that never happened
yeah I I don't know all right shut up
cheese
before we left I told my mom I was
spending the night at a friend's house
and when I got back but I didn't see any
reason to change that story and you know
what I still don't Ren always loved the
town but the island pretty much erased
that in one fell swoop he ended up going
to college in California he was my best
friend but I don't know if I'll ever see
him again
Nonna I think is going to some ballet
academy somewhere but I kind of fell out
of touch with her to be honest nobody
remembers Clarissa except me of course
and I think about her every single day
to be honest it's a strange consequence
she's replaced Michael in the pockets of
my mind that get most recalled I don't
know if it was the right thing to do I
think most people would say it wasn't
but most people will never have to face
something like that
Jonah's was the first to introduce me as
his sister you know without the step
part in front of it and it was weird at
first but it's the truth
he's my brother he goes to school in
town and we see each other a lot
[Music]
it's funny what happened on the island
used to pop into my head every single
day and then every other day and then a
week went by and I realized I hadn't
thought about it at all
I guess that's I don't know I it's good
I think
but anyways I um
well if it matters I decided to stay in
town and go to college here it's
practically up the road and I just
wanted to take in the familiar I guess
but anyways what time is it
yeah sorry I gotta run or I'll miss the
ferry runs dragging me out to Edwards
Island for that yearly beach party thing
and I have to pick up what's-his-name
Jonas - hope he's not weird or mean or
something whatever I'm sure it'll be fun
but something to do right
[Music]